is your biggest fear
that someone is going to ask you what you are going to vote for
and especially because that person will then ask
why at that party
or why on that person
you don't have to be exact
to be able to defend why you vote for 1 party
most people are satisfied if you just
I did the voting guide and I came out of this party
even if you haven't even done the voting guide
or you say this feels good
even if you are talking to 1 smartie
and that person
did you know that party
believes that all people should leave the country
and that planes are banned
Do you want that sometimes when you do
Oh
then that's fine
that's 1 fine answer
oh is 1 fine answer
if you are talking to someone
1 annoying someone who
what are you going to do with this information then you SAY
I'm going to dive in this afternoon
the people who do things like this
are just very busy displaying their knowledge
shows how smart they are
they are not busy at all
with which parties will actually vote for in the end
there is 1 chance that the party you will vote for
ends up in 1 coalition with parties
find those things you disagree with
this happened to a lot of people during the previous season
with the elections
with the people who then voted for D66
to be able to achieve something
they must then
hand in 1 number of their ideals
but this doesn't mean your voice
1 discarded voice is
it doesn't mean they haven't achieved anything
it also doesn't mean she didn't try anything
have added meaning
to the coalition agreement
or to the policy that was subsequently created
so your voice is certainly not thrown away
although it sometimes feels that way
imagine the party
where you vote for only get 1 or 2 seats
or even no seat at all
even then your voice is certainly not thrown away
in short if there are debates
then they can just join the debate of course
and they can also make adjustments
make on laws that are proposed
by the ruling parties
they may not be able to change 1 whole law
but they can certainly make the law better for it
society
or the way you want society
you could be better
vote in 1 right direction then do not vote at all
imagine you are left
but you don't know
absolutely sure whether you are now on Groenlinks PvdA
must vote for example
because everyone finds things like yes
it is good that they went together
why is Timmermans so strange and boring in the picture
of the campaign
bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
blah blah blah blah
but you are sure something needs to be done about the
climate issues
rising poverty
the housing shortage
then you better vote for that
or vote for 1 other left-wing party at all
you don't even have to tell anyone
that you voted for
you can also vote and not tell anyone
you voted for
and in 2 days
you just lie in your bed under your covers
and in 2 days everyone will be
not so much forget the elections but kind of
who are you going to vote for
what did you vote for SAY
in 2 days it will all be over you can do it